hello everyone and welcome back to the
skilling open
we are in the knockouts and this is the
second uh match of the semi-finals yanni
pomschi vs magnus carlson magnus
defeated jan yesterday
uh by winning one game we've shown that
one and the other three games ended in a
draw so now
nipple needs at least one win and for
example three draws to fourth playoffs
against magnus
and maybe uh you know head to the finals
of this
very nice tournament so without further
ado let's just check out the game
the game just ended but i thought why
not make the video on it uh
right away so it's a fairly long
theoretical struggle in the royal opus
we're not going to do well on the
opening moves uh
all that much e4 e5 knight f3 knight to
c6 and bishop to b5
so roy lopez is on the board we have a6
and bishop to a4 morphy's defense is on
the board also
knight f6 and now uh castles uh we have
bishop to e7 and now
d3 so this has been played a million
times uh
and when i say a million i mean a lot of
times d6 and c3 making room for the
light square bishop for when black
attacks it
and here we have castles by black as
well knight bd2
and rook to e8 now making room for the
bishop on f8 rook to e1
white also needs to make room for this
knight to be uh remaneuvered and now
bishop to f8
and the magnus already had this position
against firuja in the in this year's
tata steel tournament uh where uh h3 was
played by magnus and magnus was able to
win that game
uh sorry by ferugia firuja played h3 and
magnus uh won that game
however here we have d4 uh by nippon
she's so choosing a different approach
but nothing that we haven't seen before
so b5 pushing the bishop back bishop to
c2
and now e captures on d4 c captures and
bishop to g4 so white has a very strong
center here
but black has a very solid development
so here
knight to f1 uh and g6 now
if the knight comes to g3 then this pawn
will very nicely control it so
knights the g3 and the bishop is shifted
away to g7
bishop to e3 continuing development uh
and
now knight the d7 so what do you do here
here queen to d2 is a known move it was
played only in one game in the database
uh but we have rooked the c1 by nipple
and it is as of move 16 that we have a
completely new game
yes the the royal lopez is uh very well
analyzed since it's
it's one of the first opening that was
ever played
so here uh well white has to decide uh
sorry black has to decide there's a lot
of pressure here on the d4 pawn and if
black
wants to do something about it he needs
to give up uh
one of the bishops to weaken the d4
square so here
magnus captures it and now of course if
the queen captures then you can capture
the d4 pawn
so nipple is forced to mess up his pawn
structure but for now it only
strengthens uh his center if
there's going to be an attack on the
king side then it it can be considered a
weakness so here magnus goes in with
queen to f6
adds another attacker to the pawn and
nepo defends it uh well
via a small tactic bishop to b3 not
really a tactic
just saying okay if your knight moves
i'm going to capture your c7 pawn
but this is exactly what magnus goes for
we have knight captures on d4
bishop captures queen captures on d4 and
now
rook captures son c7 so putting pressure
on the knight here
uh and this is what magnus had in mind
rook to a7
and now his idea is okay if we trade
queens captures captures my rook is
again nicely defended
uh nothing to worry about here so here
after rook a7
nepal says nope we're gonna go for rook
captures queen captures
and now queen captures on d6 so we're
keeping the queens on the board
and we go into this position where i'm
up upon and if you if you'd like you
can waste the move capturing the b2 pawn
which is exactly what magnus does he
grabs the pawn and now
uh if he's able to keep his king safe he
should have a very comfortable game
but it's uh you know it's a process so
here
f4 by nipple not allowing this knife to
land on e5 so controlling that square
and also you constantly have to be
worried about any pawn pushes that might
happen
so here knight to c5 by magnus
and now comes bishop to d5
adding another defender to the e4 pawn
here and
here comes bishop to d4 here magnus is
threatening a very
very nasty tactic for example if nepo
isn't careful play something like rook
to e2 to add
a defender here it's simply sorry this
is what nipple played but if you're not
careful and play something like
h4 without the defending the pawn then
you run into
bishop captures and now white is lost
because the the rook is either lost or
you capture it and now you get let's say
knight captures an e4 check
black doesn't even have to capture the
queen you can also continue and
checkmate
checkmate white so the queen is coming
to f2 doesn't really matter what you
play with the white
check or you're going to move and our
knight captures will be checkmate
so here uh rook to e2 the move we
originally played and now comes knight
to d3 by magnus so a triple attack on
the f2 pawn
and now king to g2 nepo says okay you're
welcome to capture it but it's not gonna
come with
check and here magnus doesn't go for it
uh if you go for it for example knight
captures on f2 then you have to worry
about
you have to worry about a lot of moves
you don't have any threats here with
black
and the move like rook c2 followed by
rook c7 uh will put uh
well will put a lot of pressure on
black's position so magnus is in no rush
to capture this pawn
instead he plays king to g7 first uh
gets his king to a bit of a safer square
now the f7 pawn is not pinned
and now rook to d2 puts pressure on the
knight and here
bishop back to c5 by by magnus
forcing nepo to move the queen and
therefore lose the f4 pawn so nepo is
forced to move the queen here queen to
c6 is played
and now comes knight captures on f4 this
comes with
check so king of three and now uh now
rook to d8 here uh there are a couple of
other moves you could play
but uh you need to be careful nipple
played king to f3 because
carlson's rook is already hanging so he
played king f3 to also
make the knight hanging and magnus
really needs to figure out what to play
here
bishop to b4 is a very nice idea because
uh you threaten white's rook as well and
then if
white captures the rook black will
capture and the knight on f4 is nicely
defended while the queen guards the f7
square but it's a
it's a disgusting position to play so
here rook to d8 by
magnus uh and now comes king captures on
f4 so nepo grabs that uh grabs that
piece
uh and now rook to d6 challenging the
queen and here we have queen to e8 and
here
uh there is a move for magnus that is
pretty much
uh pretty much winning so feel free to
pause the video and
try to find this idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh to those of you who were able to
find it congratulations as it's not a
very easy move to find and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen to c7
now threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and it's uh
not at all easy for nepal to make a move
here
uh because if you do nothing then you
know any check will
will be deadly you can win the queen you
can win material you can go for a nice
checkmate the bishop doesn't allow the
king to retreat here
so whatever you try let's say king g4
you're gonna run into let's say h5
check king h3 and now rook d8 just traps
the queen so there is no way
to avoid both uh a devastating attack on
the king and losing your queen or rather
you don't lose the queen but you have to
sacrifice
uh material in order to save it you're
going to have to go for queen captures
on f7 and after we have a trade here
captures and captures you're just going
to pick up the rook here rook captures
and now
the bishop will move and you will have a
bishop and the rook against the bishop
and the knight
you wrap the exchange and of course
you're gonna win this end game very
easily
so this is what carlson had to play
however after nepo's king queen to e8
move
magnus played bishop captures on f2 and
now
uh it also looks very deadly even
deadlier than what i've
just shown you queen to e3 a very very
big threat now however there is a move
for nepo
that's uh that allows him to actually
come out
on top and gain a winning advantage so
feel free to pause the video
and find the winning move for nepal now
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredibly difficult
move to find and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
and no it's not that i'm just tricking
you it's actually king to g4
and here now magnus realized okay i
cannot go queen to e3
because my queen is needed here guarding
the f7 pawn so how do i continue this
so magnus played rook to f6 he added
another defender here and now he can
move the queen but now
nepo continues uh well with with great
style
e5 he attacks the rook and you you need
a move here and
it's not all that easy for nippo's king
the rook completely cuts him off here
uh and he will only be able to go back
so magnus goes h5
check king h3 and now rook to f4 saving
the rook
but now again in great style
e6 and now you're just threatening to
win
uh instantly here if you allow this
capture so magnus forced to capture
captures and captures and then now comes
bishop to d4 you cannot allow
rook to d4 check because you're just
going to lose the queen
so magnus blocks it with bishop to d4
but now comes
a beautiful finishing move by nipple uh
i'm sure you'll see it knight captures
on h5 i'm not going to ask you to pause
the video because there are
a lot of winning moves here this is just
the the most beautiful one nipple plays
that queen
knight captures on h5 checks the king
forks the rook and now if you just move
the king
uh you you're going to lose the rook or
even get checkmated very quickly
so magnus captured it but now comes rook
to g2 the knight sacrifice
was in order to open up the g file for
the white rook
king to f6 and now comes rook the g6
with check king e5 and bishop to b3 a
beautiful discovered
check by by nippo and it was in this
position on mu 40
that magnus carlsen resigned the game
because he's getting checkmated either
in one or two moves if king f5
uh then queen to e6 is checkmate and if
you try the other one
uh you could also block with the queen
which doesn't really make sense
then white will just capture it and
that's just it king f5 and we get the
exact same checkmate
so those are uh uh carlson's only
options
and uh a beautiful win for yanni ponchi
in round one of the second match so he's
one step closer to
dying the match and then forcing
playoffs uh we'll see if uh if magnus
can come back in this match or will we
see
some some very nice playoffs some very
nice blizz games and then maybe even
armageddon
uh so that's the game epic stuff by by
nipple
uh hope you guys enjoyed it i would like
to thank thomas sharp
patrick wetter stefan miller uh finn
chibitz and
grant miller for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage
of this very nice tournament checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your weekend